husband to trigger finds okoro and here
we go
[Applause]
okoro eats some clock now the cavs go
into motion
sexton with five to shoot works on
irving lost the ball
he had kyrie too irving
on sexton you have an offensive foul
caught on irving
oh my with a big goal made by official
suyash mehta
the indication man is that irving with
his off hand hit sexton up near the face
irving got called on a similar play
in the first quarter he pleads his case
as does james harden
a big big call let's take a look did
irving get him up
led with a forearm right in the mouth
so now the cavs can advance off the
timeout they have a second and a half
with which to work we're tied here at
113.
wow and now brooklyn's going to
challenge
not much to lose here if you're steve
nash you're right
i mean it's obvious i mean kyrie stuck
the arm up there so everybody can see it
offensive foul called on the former
cavalier playing just his second game
back in this building
since departing the cavaliers that's
gonna be a hard one to overturn ac
i agree with you i mean it was obvious
what he did i mean
he put it right up there for everybody
to see it right there
there must be clear and conclusive
visual evidence that the call was
incorrect and
have a hard time believing that they're
gonna find that here
[Applause]
coach's challenges last season were
successful 44
of the time you can challenge three
things a foul call a goaltending call or
an out of bounds call
the most difficult calls to overturn are
the foul calls like this one
overall success as mentioned 44 it goes
down to 39 percent
and you're trying to flip a foul call
well when you take the way
it looked to me john is that if his
elbow was down low it would be different
but the elbow comes out right away to
chin level
right away and that tells me right there
what his intentions are
now because the call on the floor was a
foul
if this is not overturned the cavaliers
will have the basketball
if the ball is loose in one of these
situations
it would be a jump ball at center court
this is a longer review than i thought
it would be sean wright continues to
have the headset on as does official
sueyash meta
i think it's it's that way because of
who committed to foul
because it shouldn't be that's this long
i don't think
so the review continues
[Music]
right there was the whistle and the foul
was caught on irving
now the question is
the ball is deemed to be loose should be
a jump ball at center court
yeah that i think that's what he was
pointing to
the call is overturned the clock stays
at 1.5
the ball will be put at center circle 82
can jump
wow so the call is overturned that's why
it's going to be a jump on the center
circle
because the call is overturned seeing
that there should not have been a foul
called so it's a loose ball they jump
at center court if it would have been
deemed to foul on urban the cavaliers
would have got the basketball out of had
a chance to advance
had a second and a half to set up the
play and i i'd love to hear an
explanation for this
well they probably said because sexton
reached in
that's the only thing i could see the
fact that sec they're saying
sexton reached in instead of
letting the elbow come to him he went to
the elbow that's the only thing i can
see i
don't imagine when irving went high with
the forearm sexton did go
low trying to knock it away from kyrie
so a second and a half remains
and frankly if no foul was called the
cavs are fortunate that this was a jump
ball at
center court instead of the alternative
the foul would have been called on
sexton so alan wisely is going to poke
it
into brooklyn real estate and
we're headed to overtime oh boy what a
wild
finish to regulation wow
on to overtime we go kevin durant has 30
points
as does kyrie irving james harden 17
as those three play together on the
floor for the first time here tonight 48
minutes not enough to decide it on to
overtime we go here
from downtown cleveland